دبي ، مدينة عالمية نشأت
من الصحراء التي بنيت في بضعة
عقود فقط تغذيها آبار النفط MRT DJ
والمنتج SM Freya المعروف أيضًا باسم الآيس
كريم شهد هذا التحول بشكل
مباشر الذي ألهمه لمتابعة
مهنة في الموسيقى ، لقد كان مجرد فكرة سخيفة
لإخباره  لك أن تخبرك
يا والدينا ، استمع ، أريد
أن أكون مغني راب ، ما الذي يزيل النعال
كما تعلم ، هذا أمر مخز ،
هذا ليس مخزيًا لأنك تحب
الأفلام التي تحب Netflix ولكن لا يمكنني أن
أكون  الرجل الذي تشاهده على Netflix ،
لا يمكنني أن أكون الرجل الذي يفوز
بجائزة Grammys التي فازت بجائزة
الأوسكار ، أحتاج إلى كرسي عندما يكون
الوعي صحيحًا ، فقد يكون Sam في
طريقه لتحقيق هذا النوع من
النجاح  عمل بالفعل مع
أمثال ويكليف جين
وقد أدت دقاته السريعة في الفخ إلى عقد صفقة قياسية
مع المنتج
الثنائي كول آند دري الحائز على جائزة جرامي والذي كان مسؤولاً عن
الكثير من أحدث ألبومات بيونسيه وجاي زي.
تأتي العديد من التحديات
بما في ذلك العلاقة مع
والده ، لذا فقد دعمني في
البداية ، كان من المفترض أن أعطي
شيئًا في المقابل وهو
درجة البكالوريوس ، يبدو
أنه أسهل شيء في العالم ،
صحيح أنني خرقت وعدي مرارًا
وتكرارًا  ولكي أكون صادقًا معك ،
فقد سئم الخلاف بين الاثنين ، وفي وقت ما لم
يتكلم لمدة أربع سنوات مما دفعه
أكثر لتحقيق حلمه في الواقع حيث
بدأ مسيرته الموسيقية في أبو ظبي
بعد أن عاش في باريس معظم حياته.
الحياة أنشأت علامة تسجيل بوتيك ، لقد
تعلمت الكثير عن صناعة الموسيقى
بعد بضع سنوات من القيام بذلك أدركت
أنه في نهاية المطاف لما أردت القيام به
كانت الوجهة الولايات المتحدة ومن ثم عبر
ذلك العالم قبل عشر سنوات لم يكن هناك
شيء حقًا  من حيث
مشهد الهيب هوب والآن يزدهر شيئًا
فشيئًا. هدفه الآن هو
دعم والعمل مع المزيد من الأصوات من
العالم العربي بما في ذلك مغني الراب السعودي
مجيد الذي تحدث معه مؤخرًا
نظرًا لأن ميدان الألبوم الليلي ، أعتقد أن هؤلاء الرجال
ليس فقط دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ولكن العرب الحضريين
بشكل عام لديهم القدرة على
الهيمنة حقًا في المستقبل لأن هؤلاء
الرجال لديهم الكثير من الألم والكثير من
الجوهر ولديهم الكثير من
التوقعات الثقافية العائلية الشخصية التي
لديهم '  لقد اضطررنا للتغلب على القيام
بأشياء أساسية حتى تعرف أنك أخيرًا رأوا
شخصًا ما يفعل ذلك وشخصًا آخر
يفعل ذلك وشخصًا آخر يفعل ذلك ،
إنهم مثل يا إلهي أعتقد أن هذا هو
وقتنا ، لذلك أنت
تخلق حركة تخلقها الزخم  ويتبع الناس
حركة يأمل أسام أن
يتردد صداها في جميع أنحاء المنطقة لتمكين
الجيل القادم ليس فقط لمتابعة
أحلامهم ولكن لمشاركة قصصهم
مع العالم.